what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss
naruto and specifically his hype and
tragic
new form so make sure to stay tuned for
that if you do enjoy seeing naruto and
boruto videos on this channel and want
to keep them coming then the best thing
you can do
is smash that like button hard and share
this video
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto and boruto videos
so if you haven't make this the day you
subscribe
and as you wait for the next borto
chapter or video to drop
feel free to check out my growing naruto
slash boruto playlist where i got videos
about the hokage
olotutsuki all uzumaki and more link in
the description
and in the comments of these videos you
can always leave other suggestions for
naruto slash boruto videos you want to
see and i've also been hanging out on
twitch pretty much
daily so if you want to come talk about
naruto and other anime follow me there
link in the description
now without further ado let's jump into
it so let's go over what we know so far
as you probably know ishiki has been
fighting the combined forces of naruto
sasuke and boruto and he's been crushing
them
seemingly without even really trying if
we remember back to their first fight
against
jigen we'll get an even better sense of
how strong ishiki is now
and thus how strong naruto's new form
will have to be
jigen's body as a vessel was called a
defective failure by ishiki and yet in
that body ishiki was still able to beat
naruto and sasuke working together he
was able to beat them both to a pulp
and seal naruto away although naruto did
help sasuke escape
though barely so already a very
imperfect vessel was straight up
overpowering their combined forces
then fast forward to the reincarnated
ishiki the reincarnated ishiki although
he has a time limit
is much stronger than he was when he was
just using jigen's body
kashin koji who faced both points out
that jigen is on a whole different level
of power
after being reincarnated and ishiki
himself
says that after his reincarnation his
whole body is brimming with incredible
power
and that is actually why he gives
himself only two or three days left
because the vessel cannot withstand such
power so this is actually kind of
similar to naruto's new form
but we'll be getting to that soon lastly
i'll mention what boruto said he told
naruto before this most recent fight got
underway and i quote
i'm worried you two meaning naruto and
sasuke
lost against that jegan guy last time
didn't you
so how do you plan to win against an
even stronger guy
end quote that right there's the million
dollar question and we'll be examining
it
in this video and of course boruto was
right to be worried because ishiki was
just
toying with naruto and sasuke i
mentioned in a previous chapter review
that sasuke got yamcha
meaning he was absolutely overcome by
the power gap between him and his enemy
and for a character as strong as sasuke
in the naruto world
to get yamcha that takes a pretty crazy
strong opponent
so just as all hope seems lost we get
the conversation between kurama and
naruto
naruto straight up tells him he's gonna
die protecting the village
that's what a hokage does he's ready to
die he just hopes
that he can distract ishiki as long as
possible until he does die
when kurama realizes that naruto has no
real plan except dying he decides that
since naruto is already prepared to die
there might be another way meaning that
kurama believes
this way can actually compete with or
even defeat ishiki
although it will cause naruto his life
this is huge
because if a weaker ishiki could defeat
the combined force of naruto and sasuke
then this means naruto's new form will
completely separate him from sasuke in
terms of power
his lifelong rival and so sasuke is
going to get vegeta
as well as yamcha definitely not a great
time for sasuke fans
kurama goes on to tell naruto that this
way he speaks of
is do or die last stand ace up your
sleeve kind of thing
only worth trying since naruto is
expecting to get killed anyway
and this is a huge reveal since we
followed these guys for so long
and we never knew about this ace up
their sleeve
and when naruto asks why kurama never
brought it up before
he says because naruto will die he says
do this
and it's over so there's seemingly no
gray area here
or you only have a 10 chance of survival
kind of thing
kurama says that if naruto uses this
form he'll die
kurima is only bringing it up now since
naruto will be killed
either way so might as well go out with
a bang naruto then tells kurama he's
ready
and bam we see the new form that shocked
sasuke who barely recognizes him and
even ishiki the usually composed
overpowering presence is shocked
thinking wtf what's with this chakra end
quote
so clearly it's suggested that this is
by far the strongest naruto has
ever been this will be his strongest
form
kurima believes enough that this form
might make a difference that he brought
it up
even if it means certain death just like
ishiki
this form seems to have a time limit and
be irreversible
we've seen something like this plenty of
times in shonen where a character
transfers their life force
into power thus shortening their
lifespan this seems to be the same kind
of thing except rather than just
shortening it
it seems to be irreversible once started
implying that once undertaken the form
cannot be undone
in order to save what remains of the
user's life we've seen a similar thing
even in naruto
where if you open the gate of death
you'll become unimaginably stronger but
it will almost certainly cost you your
life
as happened with might guy's dad might
die another parallel is escanor from
seven deadly sins and how he can convert
his life energy to become the one
ultimate i think similarly naruto's form
will burn through his life energy
in exchange for these kinds of insane
levels of power
a level of power that in my view will at
least equal ishiki's
now the question is will this form
really kill naruto the protagonist we've
been following for years and years
the character we've watched grow from
being an underachieving and lonely kid
to the adult hero of his village i don't
think so
i think there will be some kind of
loophole not yet obvious that will
ensure that naruto survives
if we look at the future scene we got
where boruto faces kawaki with the karma
mark
he says he'll send boruto where he sent
naruto if we assume that the karma is
ishiki's he could be identifying with
ishiki
and referring to where ishiki sent
naruto during this fight that we are
witnessing right now in the manga now
some people think this is proof that
naruto won't die
but to be fair you could send someone to
the afterlife
so it's not out of the question but i do
believe that naruto was sent to another
dimension
sealed away and that's what kawaki
ishiki meant
i've heard interesting theories from you
guys while streaming on twitch including
ideas like naruto might die
and sasuke may use renee rebirth
sacrificing himself to bring him back
but i'm thinking that this new form is
going to put up a good fight against
ishiki
exhaust a lot of his remaining power and
that ishiki will somehow manage to seal
away naruto
and by sealing him away he will perhaps
stop or
undo the usually irreversible new form
transformation
then with what little strength and time
he has left
ishiki will find and implant his karma
into kawaki
before disappearing then we'd have a
situation where naruto
is not present to save him and boruto is
forced to step up and train in order to
stop kawaki slash ishiki
and eventually he will save naruto who
will not die because the deadly new form
was
undone in a sense through the ceiling
this is of course just some thoughts
that make sense to me right now
and things may not turn out like this
but i really don't want to believe that
naruto will die and i think that would
be a bad decision on their part
if they did have him die cause it's
freaking naruto and because
when he reveals stuff like his new form
it's like the most exciting thing ever
and we don't want to lose that but yeah
anyways there is little doubt that this
costly form is the strongest naruto's
ever been and although we know because
of the time skip scene that naruto won't
solve everything right here and now
i still can't wait to see this op form
in action
let me know your thoughts about this new
form how strong you think it is
and what will happen moving forward in
the manga just let me know in the
comments if you did enjoy this video and
want to keep the naruto slash boruto
videos coming
make sure to smash that like button to
let me know and share this video with
any fellow naruto fans
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select all or you will miss
future naruto such boruto videos which
you
definitely don't want to happen right
now because this is the best boruto has
ever been
so if you haven't make this the day you
subscribe
and as you wait for the next exciting
boruto chapter or video to drop
feel free to check out my growing naruto
boruto playlist where i got videos about
the hokage all ototsuki
all uzumaki and much more link to that
is in the description and i've also been
hanging out on twitch pretty
much daily so if you want to come talk
about naruto and other anime follow me
there
also linked in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord twego himself alpha sigma and are
the one tier patrons the ones who stand
atop
all clans in grata the world acquire
respect
liam thompson pate heffa red haired
raven
emperor otaku thomas jones spidey life
tinnell
and baked buddhist and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh who's
the current most donated overall
champion of the world
steelers angel cruz anatoly kazatsky
cricket xp
joe stanton rethurin they aura very
gucci jessica kayla fawn alicia actor
hinokami and water bonnie parks
florian joanne garcia jack watches anime
deadly saint
high school dxd73 matthew cruz and
anthony schreiber thank you all so much
if you do enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patreon
today for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here
and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested
you can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button
next to the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
choose to support us
you can get the same great benefits and
until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you